because if you can you're in the back oh
I hope I think it might be a Brenda hey
what's going on everybody for first we
feast I'm Sean Evans and you're watching
hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today I'm joined by Bert Kreischer Bert
the Conqueror Bert the Machine Bert the
hot ones fan finally we get you in the
seat hardcore hot ones fan I have notes
on the show I I want to critique the
shows that I've watched in the past my
favorite ones I'm so happy that I'm a
part of this you were one of our first
famous day one hot ones fans back when
we weren't [ __ ] you're talking about us
in the Bert cast it gave us life to a
big hip-hop fan okay so as soon as I
started seeing rappers I was like yes
and then one day you turned a corner and
you've got riff raff and I watched him
go full burly boy and I literally I was
like I was like I the accents fading
away the characters fading away he can't
rhyme him and it was like this is great
you're sizzling down what is an
entertainer you're taking it to the in
he said these are these are the ones
that are I believe game changers no
questions asked TJ Miller yeah squirt
water bottle in the face key and Peele
Jordan when he just starts going that's
when you watch it you're like oh shut up
and then I'm obviously dj khaled oh okay
I'm sorry I'm sorry
best one yet easily when I show the show
to anyone the one I show is Eddie Wong
when he stands up and he starts going
home huh
well that's when you're like oh [ __ ]
it's on and then when he comes back to
every touched his dick are you serious
yeah it was like we really put him
through some stuff I want to be sweating
profusely throughout that's a lot I can
already feel it
[Music]
all right let's start this way Shawn the
proper way to eat a win you guys have
always been doing it wrong okay you guys
go at it like savages just oh right oh
my god no take a lot win is eaten like
this you just wake it you twist you then
take this bone okay okay you slide it
out this one yeah
then you've got basically like a little
meat no mm-hmm not bad at all I want to
start at the beginning because you burst
on the scene in such an odd way there's
this Rolling Stone profile they come to
visit Florida State and they want to do
a story on the party scene at Florida
State and it ends up evolving this huge
profile piece at that time in your life
as a 60 year senior it had to be odd
because you have classmates who are
probably stressing out about their first
entry-level job and you're getting
courted by the national media because of
your ability to shotgun beers and have a
good time how did that shift your
perspective as an adult and what life
could be if I feel like I'm just the
luckiest guy in the world like that
happened I'd be selling carpets in East
Georgia I mean I was the our path was
either selling boats in Orlando or
selling carpets in East Georgia and I
didn't this happen all of a sudden I had
opportunity I had an opportunity to have
a morning show in Tallahassee I had an
opportunity to move to New York do
stand-up and then when I got to New York
I had an opportunity to to do something
and then how people want to talk to me
they're like there's an interesting
article tell me more about yourself and
that's how I met will so that will
Schmitt yeah and that's an odd story to
write well yeah yeah funny word of
[ __ ] yeah that's if you thought you
would not I like a Hollywood thing your
dad talking to dad [ __ ] Hollywood [ __ ]
me in the ass cuz well psych let's go to
the movies and I was like okay and I
told my dad we're going the movies my
dad's old school is like wait I got a
date and I was like no he's like who
goes to the movies he's like funny this
is very popular in Hollywood the the big
movie stars get so tired of women they
just want to turn out young boys that's
what he wants to do with you I was like
that's impossible he's like what's more
likely the fact that you're so talented
that the biggest movie star in the world
wants to make a sitcom about you or that
he's tired of
and he wants to [ __ ] you in the ass
holes like [ __ ] cuz that makes a lot of
sense what your dad says what makes a
lot of is a lot more sense of me being
talented and then I got there and I told
him I was a big hip-hop fan you know
thinking that's how we connect we got
there and this got Charlie Mac 65 350
meets me and he's like downstairs I
don't think I gotta [ __ ] this guy - and
then there's ten dudes in the room all
black dudes in a small room like this
and a folding table and I'm like if
you're gonna have quite the afternoon
I'm sure he's bringing Jazzy Jeff that
counts 13 on my watch
I know we just watched a movie he showed
up he brought you a see Jeff we watched
the movie and it was great at the end he
was like what you think cause it was
fantastic he's like no about the the
guys I was like they're black and he's
like no you've said you're a hip-hop fan
that's cool Monty that's Biz Markie and
I was like oh my god I could have [ __ ]
Cody so yeah yeah is uh was a real entry
into this business man Tapatio mm-hmm I
eat this for breakfast so you're an
oddball with a lot of quirks and one of
the stranger things that you do is you
leave these messes behind in hotel rooms
which are actually these kind of
mesmerizing artistic figures do you
remember the first time you did that and
why you know the first one is it was in
San Antonio Texas
and I did it because as I was leaving
the room I looked at the room and I
thought to myself if this maid has any
insight she could figure out what I did
in this room very quickly like there's a
lotion by the bed there's a towel by the
lotion how gross would that be to come
in and be like oh great this guy just
jacked off in here I tried to throw her
off the trail from her finding I was
masturbating and so I put a learning
board and a pillow and I put pillows
around the toilet and I put a spoon next
to that like I like it just to try to
confuse her and think what would the
main thing and then the next one I did I
put my shortening pillow in the in the
refrigerator so when she open the
refrigerator looked at there was a torso
in the refrigerator yeah and this
actually like looks like it requires
some talent it really could be in a
Contemporary Art Museum add some some
artist came up to me it's like dude
you're great composition I was like I
don't mean oh the [ __ ] that means I get
in these manic states ride you like five
and night and I just like shoes by the
under the curtain and like legs out of
this table and then the lamp looks like
et and then and then a mummy wrap to
toilet paper on the bed and a toilet
that looks like a snake and I just get
I mean manic like a crazy person so this
is a Yucatec Oh Caribbean habanero it's
probably a little fruity a no-show
so I'm birthda conquer you travel to all
these amazing attractions you probably
Bend every amusement park there is as a
man child who's logged a lot of hours at
those types of places are there things
that you can do so you don't end up
ruining a Saturday okay
number one you have to get the Fastpass
there's no questions about it gets Fast
Pass it is a waste of money to go to an
amusement park if you don't get there
fast fast number two um as a dad dip out
and have beers that's the most beautiful
thing about an amusement park just dip
out get a beer walk it off
hop on a ride hey I'm gonna take a break
another one get your cardio by doing the
basketball game anytime you walk by that
basketball thing and you see the kid on
the basketball if you yell throw me the
rock he passes it to you immediately he
doesn't care
don't just butch it unaggressive
three-pointer throw me the rock just
boom and then just ya the key to the
hammer thing mm-hmm
it's not power as this just hit it dead
center in the center hit it solid cone
and it hits it every time didn't know
good to know you're ready to move on am
i sweating through my shirt yet we're
spotting a little yeah oh my god this
shirts coming off there are very few
people who are famous for partying it's
like you and it's steve-o might have
Tucker max that seems like the world's
greatest job description but a difficult
reputation to uphold when you're Burt
the party guy and you go out on a Friday
or Saturday night what's the worst thing
about having to try to uphold that kind
of reputation shots right cuz everyone
always wants to buy you shots I get it
like I totally get it but man I can only
do so many shots no one offers me drugs
no one offers me weed
it's bits shots dude up and down shots
I'll get a beer I'll go onstage for
stand-up and I'll take a sip and nobody
pound it I'm like I'm drinking for me
like I'm the one that gets the buzz I
don't worry I want it like I don't like
sleeping sober
not gonna [ __ ] go to my hotel room
and like a person dead inside just close
my eyes and go to bed yeah I'm gonna
drink for me and I'll drink in my hotel
room for me but like let me go on my own
pace
[Applause]
so this one you already know it's the
hot ones hot sauce this is your hot
sauce we got you a bottle oh [ __ ] well
we'll see how I like that as you
probably know sometimes it's a little
bit of a crutch that we have on hot ones
we like to do deep dives on people's
instagrams or and get a little bit more
believable almost halfway through like
I'm not I was like I was like I'm gonna
have to I'm gonna definitely get it my I
by that time is it everything you
expected and more oh it's beyond it all
right explain to me what's going on here
we did a show called the condom Comedy
Jam the guy to the far left my far left
is Josh out of Meyers a taste show it's
comics we go up we do stand-up and then
we sing a song and that was my
interpretation of Sun Temple Pilots
because that's what's gonna stand out on
this photos you see that everybody is
wearing clothes yeah except for you
birds see I take it I take it to the
next level if you can if you look a
little further into someone else's
Instagram I'd Red Hot Chili Peppers two
weeks ago with a sock on my [ __ ] you're
just a performer and you're just
committee hears you Annie Andrew W K
yeah so two party icons here but in kind
of different ways
we were doing my buddy Mike Altos radio
show in Tampa and I was doing I've
wanted to party with Andrew W K forever
and so I cracked a beer I was like let's
drink it's like 8:00 in the morning he
was like I gotta work out later you know
party like that news like I mean I'll
have a beer but I'm not I'm not partying
right now and I was like so let down
right he's not and he's not a party
animal in the conventional sense no he's
not like in like the alcoholic sense
right like he's just a be just throws
parties it's a philosophy brand he's a
really smart guy too
definitely but yeah that's me and him
partying but I was partying he's
shirtless yeah he was like why is your
shirt off and I was like hold on these
aren't questions partiers ask other
partiers and one more for ya at the
hobbit house yeah yeah we went down we
did a for Travel Channel we did a thing
with uh with Peter Jackson one of the
most beautiful places in the world if
you've got a 13-hour flight under your
belt that's the place to go go to New
Zealand go to Queenstown go to Hobbiton
go to
go to go to New Zealand that place is
gorgeous
that place is overwhelming how are you
doing so far I'm doing really good this
is the best tasting one I've had yet
thank this has had the most kick mm-hmm
well this will have the most game number
six hi River rogue oh yeah oh [ __ ] it's
on the back of my tongue mm-hmm we're on
the sides of the back of my tongue
mm-hmm yeah looking about raveling a
really real when people travel they
always say I want the local experience
and you really took that to the next
level when you became a de facto member
of the Mafia on a class trip to Russia I
know you've told the Machine routine
50,000 times so I'm not gonna ask you to
do it again if you're a fan of birds
though if you're a fan of our show you
should check that out because it's a
legendary story some people say it's the
best story ever told even yeah but I
want to know about a story of you
traveling abroad that sort of goes under
the radar flung dildos flying dildos I
like where this is going
yeah whoa man I really talked to my it's
nice it's like it's like right there
it's like an edible like it's not too
much yet you know I mean but you know
it's gone mm-hmm I was in Amsterdam when
I was in college right after the Russian
mob story as with my buddies and I saw
signs head flying dildos I got guys
we're getting tickets won't find dildos
naturally and we go in to find dildos
and it's a live sexually verb in the
livestock show not a frog I'm very
aggressive Furcal comes up and Jimmy n--
like I'm not big for play guy but total
lack of or black kind of looks like an
assault right and she just starts [ __ ]
going yard and her put just Hong Kong
and we're just like oh and she just I
mean literally giving herself a
gynecological exam in front of us and
like oh that's her uvula and then she
gets off more like that's not flying
dildos and then two girls come on and
then they start like making out and
we're like no you can't go back in the
story like we just watched it one fists
herself you need to step it up ladies
especially cuz you thought you were
getting the headliner right off the blue
want flying dildos and so I start
talking to him and I'm like do you guys
do flying dildos and like no beat it and
then then like a girl comes out by
herself with like I've already seen it
in it and like you don't fly and dildos
go then a guy comes out and the guys
like then I'm it hard yet
like I'm step up your game and he's do a
crowd work he's like yeah you ready to
see me [ __ ] and we know it's not flying
Dilla's him and the girl and so I start
heckling his dick and then he starts to
fluff it and I'm like hey think about
your mom he's like [ __ ] you and I was
like you got a sister and he's like hey
man I'm not cool and then he storms off
and now I'm running the show
I'm chanting we won't flying dildos and
the place is going nuts they're stomping
I'm like Barack Obama to these guys not
yeah
way before Barack Obama was even Brock
Obama but like in Grant Park with the
tearful goose Beach I'm up there like
you want to change and then a woman
comes out thigh high boots leather
bikers cap medicine bag slams and down
she goes gentlemen please I am flying
dos the place goes [ __ ] bananas it's
like it's like control room to NASA on
Apollo 13 we're lighting cigarettes were
high-fiving and she's like calm down I
will need the one volunteer from the
audience yeah so I get up there and I'm
like I'm like not only am i I'm getting
to see I'm a part of the show I'm part
of flying dildos I'm up there with like
getting ready to give a speech I didn't
realize she puts a handcuff on me to put
second handcuff on me now I'm locked and
I'm looking her like this is moving
really fat but real respects real and
these guys see it my eyes and now
they're seeing something real and
they're like oh and I'm like now slow
down guys like I go how do we do this
and she's not joking swipes my legs
knocks me on my back and knocks the wind
out of me and I make that noise at home
yeah as I'm doing that she rips my pants
off me my dick falls out of my boxers I
look at my best friend we - who is this
close to me in the front row and I go
poke it back in please and he's like I
will not be doing that and then she
stands above me and proceeds to xcalibur
a 12-inch black dildo into my mouth you
have a choice at that moment you can
either try to block the shot purse your
lips close your teeth possibly losing
teeth in a foreign country right or you
acquiesce and let her go yard in your
jaw I chose the latter
just just X just comb goes like eight
inches back I'm gagging the winds
knocked out of me my dicks out of my
boxers I look like the very last unicorn
and she goes gentlemen this is flying
dildos get your cameras
[Music]
paying 100 yeah this is where we start
tasting battery acid pain 100 to me is
the worst tasting sauce I've ever had in
my life and I've had like every hot
sauce oh [ __ ] that mm-hmm right it
doesn't taste like food mm-hmm it makes
it taste like poison no it's right [ __ ]
huh so in my opinion Loki
one of the most underappreciated deep
cable experiments who was hurt Burt
oh look all right because it was great
remember you tried out for an arena
football team and you got shattered to a
thousand pieces by blitzing linebackers
who you did that thing where you tried
to be a rodeo clown and you caught a
full bowl right to the chest uh-huh
what's the closest do you think you've
ever been to death on camera oh right
now no that was it just doesn't even
taste good like yeah that's the point of
food is you want it to set be summable I
think uh probably without a doubt um the
bull fighting that bull was it one of
the most stupid things I've ever done in
my life and I won't work with big
animals like that ever again
I went Adam and I went to go get in his
nook and he didn't want it and then he
broke my ribs broke my foot it feels
good when you breathe in it hurts to
talk like huh had a friend say tree
poison with poison she's like bring red
wine and I was like I don't know that
sounds like a good idea that's bad
advice horrible idea but yeah that my
bull squared you up it knocked I mean
that show is a brilliant concept it was
ahead of its time you ready to move oh
no do they get better no it gets worse
that's how the show is designed Jesus
Christ
of these last three which is the
best-tasting Mad Dog 357 okay I have
something look forward to you ready
yeah so I want to talk about the Burke
cast and podcasting in general because
it seems to be this whole community
where these comedians the
cross-pollinating they're appearing on
each other shows but I know from talking
to a lot of comedians but there's also a
lot of jealousy and a lot of
backstabbing in that community do you
think that the podcast has helped to
bring the comedy community together or
do you think having these guys shooting
the [ __ ] in a very lacks chill
environment or they're telling anecdotes
and stories oftentimes involving other
famous people do you think that it's
further fractured comedy community oh
[ __ ] never does water oh I got all that
juice down my throat podcasting in the
very beginning oh my god I feel like I'm
just in a closet talking to myself if we
every one just talk [ __ ] you don't even
realize you talk [ __ ] he's just talking
[ __ ]
normal sudden someone calls you and
they're like guy man that's what you
think I mean you're like I didn't know
you heard that a literal podcast one
time I talk [ __ ] about TJ Miller who I
like and then he was on a show he's
called me and he was like whoa just like
that I was like I don't know I was high
I was high and if I didn't mean it and
he was like with her mighty thing I was
like no and then he was just like I was
rocky jetty and I was like ah yeah I
really agree and uh holy god I'm like
euphoric right now mm-hmm
and I really loved TJ and the thing that
sucks is my kids love his movies and I
like his movies and then all the sudden
for like you mean it matters I think I'm
I said [ __ ] something about Chris D'Elia
the other day and I like Chris but I
don't know the [ __ ] I said I was just
talking to somebody and then someone
said something I don't disagree and then
then you go oh [ __ ] I really like Chris
I hope he's not mad I don't know what
the [ __ ] I said I'm not gonna back and
listen to podcast I like D'Elia I like
TJ look maybe I'm jealous with them I
don't [ __ ] know okay but like they're
really good guys [ __ ] me
what do you do with that one I was about
to eat it well we're gonna next one hmm
I just take my shirt off just for a
second yeah go ahead it's like I'm
[ __ ] I got it I got a Mike I know
you're doing
we got a boom I've been doing the
television for seven years we got this
you look great
yeah I've lost uh lost a lot of weight
yeah cuz you get your in that whole
thing with Tom it's a fat shaming thing
that my fatter friend picked to do [ __ ]
a lot of questions were answered in the
show sometimes I was like I didn't think
he took a big enough bite and I'm like
oh it took plenty so all comedians have
to deal with hecklers but as somebody
you know who does the stand-up with his
shirt off is the party guy the rager my
guess is that you stir up crowds in a
way that's kind of unique and probably
cause scenes that are a little more
chaotic than your average comedian I was
in Miami these three gangbangers up
front were heckling the host so bad she
started crying when the next guy had
thin hair and his hair was matted down
and he was emotional I asked the manager
if they could ex corde him out things
like we can't they have weapons I was
like how am I supposed to deal with them
and he's like I'm gingerly I guess so I
went out I was like a little trick but
you ask them questions you already have
a joke for set him up yeah and it's
going really glowingly schedule loving
me so I turn to my left to tell a joke I
run the big the blackest guy of them all
gets on stage names ray gets on stage
he's like there's a real [ __ ] on
stage it's what we paid to see a real
[ __ ] you know real [ __ ]
get in the 305 and everyone's like
curious I'm praying I don't get shot and
he takes his dick out then it's massive
he goes respect so your [ __ ] son and I
was like what
he's like show yo [ __ ] and I was like
I'm not gonna take my dick out after
that like happily I better learn it
before but not now
right and I think it's illegal and I go
n ray I don't know why I remember his
name I go ray you may want to leave I'm
sure they're gonna call the cops right
and he's like good lookin out and he
gets offstage how do you follow that and
I look at his friends with dreadlocks in
the face tattoo and he just stands up
slowly I go please say was another dick
and he gets on stage and he opens his
hands just he's like you're a real
[ __ ] man that's what you get and
he shows his dick now
as dark is raised but it's just as big
like it's a [ __ ] hog and I'm like and
I go holy crap and he's going he's a
good-looking dude to show the women are
into it the guys were amazed and I go
that's fantastic he's like show yo [ __ ]
son and I go I'm definitely not after
you - yeah and I go and you may want to
go catch up with Riggs they're
definitely called the cops by now
right now he's that good lookin out he
gets off I swear to you on my children
they're hanging out with a hairless
albino and so I go as so funny out of
all the dicks yours is the only one I
want to see and everyone laughs and he
looks at me and he stands up slowly and
he walks up on stage and he drops his
pants to his ankles and it looks like a
[ __ ] lighthouse I mean it is like
white like white no hair it like just
like a lighthouse a beacon and people
are flipping over [ __ ] tables they're
like holy [ __ ] and he just raises his
hand and I look at them and I go that's
my show and I just dropped the mic and
walked off you can't follow a now I
don't got anywhere from that you can't
follow an albino [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
so I know that I know the tradition you
know what's up as we've talked about
this whole time you're one of our day
one fans we've been trying to work this
out for so long and finally you're here
and when that happens it's a great thing
but it's also kind of a bad thing
because in some way you have to be a
little let down by your experience here
you have to be disappointed in some way
it's probably something you were hoping
I'd ask you about that I didn't or some
way that you thought it was gonna go
that it didn't I wanted to take a bite
reflect and if you were to do this
differently and what ways are you
disappointed in hot ones now that you're
here okay I might be the best question
is fast okay ready
cause like I'm feels like I'm chewing up
Tylenol mm-hmm oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me oh
not this isn't good
this isn't good oh right and then I
really didn't think I'd throw up but you
might garbage can
no no no no let it happen no ah it's
just a taste I can feel it I can just
feel it
I'm feel it in the back of my throat
just give you it
Oh like you it do you feel it
how what did you repeat what do you put
your Z to go down your throat yeah
throat something that's making a feel
not so good it's a milk bitter yeah try
something you know you don't have like a
good bedside manner you're freaking me
out man you're freaking me out I'm
freaking out because I'm freaking out as
I'm visiting my throat what are you most
disappointed by how did we let you down
Bert another beer I thought you
definitely have beer for me and I could
write off getting drunk too working oh
[ __ ] dude it's just it's see if you can
hear it in the background I hope no I
think it might be a run it's similar
it's all my teeth I think if you just
maybe stop provoking it
I didn't bring it back down to earth and
or handle your high okay I feel good you
feel good I feel good and you've reached
the finish line write it Shawn Burt this
is fantastic this is exactly everything
I planned like definitely my nose
definitely my eyes all on my cheeks
definitely a part of you but you made it
through and you know what that means
what's up 30-second plug we really we
really go the extra mile for you because
you went the extra mile for us Berg my
Showtime special airs in October or
November of this year it's called the
machine follow me on YouTube
holy [ __ ] oh my god I'm feeling like I'm
gonna pass out um find the on tour go to
Burt Burt Burt calm stand-up comedy
until the end of the year oh my god my
sinuses just opened they just went right
an old lady walked in the door
[Music]
you